un prince en exil préoccupé par la
situation en Iran à 56 ans resa pas la
vie et réclame plus de pression de la
communauté internationale pour mettre
fin au régime des mots là ce que vous
devez avoir dans votre calcul
l'anticipation que ce régime pourrait
tomber à chaque moment est-ce que nous
avons
suffisamment
travaillé sur l'alternative et la raison
pour la carte selon lui l'alternative au
régime ne va pas arriver miraculeusement
cette question de temps c'est pas une
question de si mais quand il multiplie
les arguments dès que ce régime est fini
il y a plus de financement des réseaux
terroristes il y a plus de Hesbollah il
y a plus de Hamas il y a plus de menaces
nucléaires tout ceci disparaît
instantanément
le pays s'enflamme depuis la mort de
Marsa Amini 22 ans arrêté d'abord parce
que son voile était mal ajustée puis
battu à mort selon sa famille durant sa
garde à vue à Téhéran
depuis les manifestations se multiplient
1200 personnes auraient été arrêtées en
Iran des dizaines tués depuis le 16
septembre dont radis Najafi 20 ans qui
est devenu un autre symbole de
résistance en Iran
en Syrie en Turquie en Iran les femmes
se coupent les cheveux en signe de
solidarité
aujourd'hui juste un Trudeau annonce
d'autres sanctions contre le régime
iranien nous imposerons des sanctions
contre la police des mœurs dit-il
ces mouvements féministes aujourd'hui au
soutien des iraniennes où sont tous ces
mouvements qui soutiennent les droits
des de la communauté LGBTQ a besoin
d'avoir plus 40 ans d'exil après que son
père le Shah d'Iran à la tête d'une
monarchie jugée répressive fut chassé du
pouvoir par l'ayatollah communi
accueilli par le peuple en 1979
resapa la vie se décrit comme un
facilitateur et ne souhaite pas un
retour de la monarchie mais une
transition démocratique en Iran où il y
aurait séparation de l'Église et de
l'État on est fier
[Musique]
ils ont trop payé
et ils en ont assez
donc
on fait ce qu'on peut tout ce qu'on peut
mais je l'espère qu'ils vont réussir et
je sais qu'ils vont réussir c'est une
question de temps et comme il y a 40 ans
il espère que le peuple iranien aura le
dernier mot ici Radio-Canada Washington